بمجرد أن حركت الموجات فوق الصوتية
عبر معدتي، قلت يا إلهي،
هناك شيء آخر لم يكن عليها حتى أن
تخبرني به بنفسها، كان بإمكاني رؤيته
على الفور، كيلسي هاتشر، وهي أم
لثلاثة أطفال، تنتظر طفلتين في
يوم عيد الميلاد.  إنها 133 نبضة في الدقيقة
ولكن هذا الحمل وهذان التوأمان مميزان بشكل
خاص. ولدت كيلسي
برحمين وهي تحمل طفلاً
في كل منهما، ومن الواضح أن الاحتمالات
ضئيلة للغاية ولكن أه في تلك اللحظة لم
أدرك أنهما كانا نحيفين  نظرًا لأن
هذه مشيمة واحدة ثم
تبدأ في التقاط
المشيمة الأخرى، فمن النادر جدًا أن يكون لدى كيلسي رحم
دلفوس، وهي حالة يكون
لديها فيها رحمان وخدمتان،
ولديها طفل في كل رحم وهو يموت
الحمل التجويفى أو الحمل بتوأم
حيث يكون لكل منهما حجرة خاصة به
بدلاً من أن يكونا في الرحم مفصولين بغشاء
خطتنا حاليًا هي الولادة بشكل
طبيعي لقد أجريت ثلاث
ولادات طبيعية ناجحة قبل أن
أقوم بالولادة من كلا الرحمين في
الماضي أيضًا  لذا فإن هذا أمر جيد بالنسبة لنا، حيث
يأمل الأطباء الآن أن
يدخل جسدي في مرحلة المخاض التلقائي
ويعتني بنفسه، وعليك أن
تتكيف مع ما نعرفه عن
حالات الحمل بتوأم مع هذا
الوضع المحدد الذي احتاجته قليلاً
المزيد من الاهتمام الإضافي، لقد تمت رؤيتها
في زيارات ما قبل الولادة في كثير من الأحيان،
المخاض قبل الأوان، وهذا بالتأكيد مصدر قلق كبير. لقد
رأيت سيدات حوامل منذ حوالي
50 عامًا، لذا أه إنه بالتأكيد
أمر نادر الحدوث وأنت تعلم أنه لا يمكنك أبدًا أن
تقول أبدًا  أعتقد في الطب ولكن
سيكون من المستبعد جدًا جدًا
إذا رأيت فتاتين مرة أخرى، فقد
يكون هناك ولد، أعرف أن والدك يظل
يأمل أن أكون متحمسًا جدًا
لمقابلتهم خاصة الآن بعد أن تقدموا في
السن في عمر الحمل  لقد حصلنا على
بعض الموجات فوق الصوتية ونراها تبدو
مختلفة قليلاً، فلا أحد من أطفالي
يشبهني، كلهم ​​يشبهون أبي، لذلك
آمل أن يكون لدي طفل
يشبهني على الأقل ولكننا سنرى